Taylor Swift's stuck mid-air during a
tour stop like Shelton takes a spill on
stage and Michelle Obama lives her best
life at Beyonce and jay-z concert well
friends I hope your Monday is off to a
better start than mine
I literally spilled my breakfast all
over me this morning so I'm a hot mess
Express but it looks like I'm not the
only one going through it no there were
a couple stage snafus this weekend
Taylor Swift found herself in a delicate
situation in Philly she was stranded for
about two minutes after her sparkly
perch got stuck high above the crowd
[Applause]
[Music]
she missed that cue though you get that
tey handle it like a pro duh she turned
the concert malfunction into a memorable
moment busting out two acapella songs to
pass the time including a Taylor classic
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
alright that was a cute moment but still
a bit of a bummer though because I saw
the reputation tour here in Los Angeles
and Taylor Swift floating through the
stadium like a sparkly unicorn was a
cool sight to see so sorry guys in
Philly but I mean while an Oregon Blake
Shelton had his own stage snafu the 42
year old tripped and fell while
performing at a music festival
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Blake later joked on Twitter he had been
drinking a lot but it might also be
pitbulls fault who also performed at the
fest because Blake tweeted by the way
pitbull a blame you
it was my attempt at competing with your
show I am a dancing son of a [ __ ] when
I don't take a ten-second giant fall and
you know someone who knows a thing or
two about stage malfunctions is Beyonce
you guys remember when she was stuck on
that elevated stage during a on the run
to tour stop and had to take an
emergency ladder back down yeah the show
must go on but thankfully B and hubby
jay-z's perished show went off without a
hitch but they had the best opener the
freaking World Cup final where France
won the whole thing
[Applause]
have you ever seen a crowd going ape fan
showed up four hours ahead of the cop
the Carters concert to watch what is
being held as one of the best World Cup
games of all time but imagine watching
your home country win the World Cup and
then jam out to Beyonce and jay-z live
that is an epic tournament among the
famous faces in that crowd at the Paris
show the Jonas Brothers and Joe's
fiancee sophie Turner and get this
Michelle Obama who was living her best
life jamming alongside Beyonce's mama
miss Tina
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
miss Tina couldn't hang but you see
Michelle Obama get it epic speaking of
I've got one last treat for you guys
tomorrow is the first round of judges
cuts on America's Got Talent and I've
got an exclusive sneak peek at all-male
Filipino dance group junior new system
who channeled their inner Jennifer Lopez
with a show-stopping routine in heels
just wait for I'm so happy to see you
how are you guys feeling about tonight
we're so nervous because it's the middle
around and at the same time we're
excited because if you have a dream just
believe it and you can do it good luck
thank you so much
let's go
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what you got
right I literally look like I could be
in that group but we'll find out if my
Pinoy brothers make it through to the
next round when a GT airs Tuesday night
on NBC until then make sure y'all are
subscribe to ETS YouTube channel because
tonight Entertainment Tonight is sitting
down with the one and only Britney
Spears she looks back on her Mickey
Mouse Club days and baby one more time
and it's pretty amazing so I'll see you
guys tomorrow with that